-Did you guys see
that McDonald's news?
Apparently,
rapper Pusha T is mad.
He wrote the "I'm Lovin' It"
jingle and he didn't -- yeah.
So, now,
he released a diss track.
[ Laughter ]
Because he didn't get
paid enough
to write the original
"I'm Lovin' It,"
so he teamed up with Arby's
[ Laughter ]
to release a diss track called
"Spicy Fish Diss."
[ Laughter ]
This is real.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
It's pretty crazy.
Well,
McDonald's
isn't taking it lightly.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, they made their own
diss track about Arby's
and now, here to perform it live
is Ronald McDonald.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ I heard you got meats ♪
♪ Well, we got the beats ♪
♪ I heard what you said ♪
♪ So, now, we got beef ♪
♪ Your food is a joke ♪
♪ It's super obscene ♪
♪ I'm gonna leave you broken ♪
♪ Like our ice cream machine ♪
♪ We got shamrock shanks ♪
♪ Made of four-leaf clovers ♪
♪ We'll serve up your ass ♪
♪ A billion times over ♪
♪ I'll roll up with Grimace ♪
♪ I'll bring the whole group ♪
♪ You're gonna see
Golden Arches ♪
♪ When we pee on your stoop ♪
♪ Keep our name out your mouth ♪
♪ Or you're gonna get cut ♪
♪ And then you'll get
a load of ♪
♪ Mickey D's [deez] nuts ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I might be a clown ♪
♪ But you're just a myth ♪
♪ And all your fish tastes ♪
♪ Just like [bleep] ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yo, Mickey D's for life.
Shout-out, Hamburglar.
Get out soon.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright, everybody,
stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Come on back.
-♪ Mickey for life ♪
♪ Mickey for life ♪
♪♪